Although we use passwords almost
universally, very commonly,
there are plenty of
problems with passwords.
People been predicting
the demise of passwords for
a long time because of these problems,
but they sort of refuse to go away.
So what are some of these problems?
For passwords to be strong, and
by strong we mean harder to guess,
they need to be long and they need to
have these upper, lower digits, special
characters and things like that, so
we are increasing the space of possible
passwords but that increases complexity
for users and usability suffers.
Even if you have good passwords,
there are problems with sort of the
trusted paths discussion that we had.
This is sort of related to that.
Phishing and social engineering attacks,
really users don't authenticate who is
really that their giving
their password to.
So this idea of mutual authentication,
you trying to convince
that it is really you.
It's Alice.
Do you assume the system
is the true system?
Do you ever ask the system to
authenticate itself to you?
In particular if you're using
a remote service, your bank or
something like that,
how do you know it's really your bank?
It could be someone else that
just looks like your bank.
And those are the sort of
fphshing attacks that we have.
Unfortunately once a password is stolen,
it can be used many times.
Not a one time use sort of a thing, and
they can gain access to your
account again and again.
And the way we address that is
by having policies that say you
must change your password every 90 days,
or every six months, or whatever it is.
Of course, usability's going
to suffer because of that.
And finally, humans are humans, and
they have a hard time
remembering lots of passwords.
These days it's not just
one system that we have.
You have your bank, you have your mail,
you have various merchants,
retailers, and things like that, so
you have lots of passwords to remember.
You don't want to have the same password
everywhere because when one gets
compromised, you're vulnerable to
all your services that you access,
somebody can get to them with
that one stolen password.
So if you're going to
have different passwords,
well that's going It's going to be hard
for us to remember so many of those
passwords if they're really hard to
guess, and they're long and complex.
Well all of the many problems,
there are of course,
some best practices when
it comes to passwords.
So when it comes to Sys administrators,
obviously the password should
never be stored in the clear.
So you only store hashed values.
And we use salting, random salt,
to avoid the problems,
multiple users having the same
password and things like that.
We have to limit access to the file
where these passwords are stored,
the hash values are stored, so
shadow files we talked about and so on.
And we want to use a function
here that is not fast.
We have to do it only once it's
in it once the user logs in.
We don't need to run it a million times.
So it doesn't have to be fast,
it can be slow.
On the other hand,
somebody doing a brute force attack
has to run it again and again.
They have to run it millions of times.
So using a slow function
actually is helpful, and
current implementations
actually do that.
They use slower hash functions.
What users can do is,
a lot of password managers these days,
we're talking about having
lot of passwords, one for
each different service you want to
use and hard to remember all of them.
Password managers actually can
generate complex high entropy.
We didn't talk about
the word entropy but
entropy is sort of high entropy means
it's harder to guess, so they can
have these difficult to guess passwords
and they can keep track of those.
You basically have one strong password
to access the password manager and
they can keep track of
your other passwords.